WESTON HUTCHINS: We're going
to be talking today primarily
about Anthos, and more
specifically GKE On-Prem.
So quick intros-- my
name is Western Hutchins.
I am a product manager
for GKE On-Prem,
and I brought some fine
folks with me today.
Do you want to
introduce yourselves?
KYLE BASSETT: Sure.
Kyle Bassett, partner at Arctiq.
Been working on Anthos
project for a while
closely with Wes since
last year at Next.
So excited to show
you some of the stuff
we've been working on, and with
Dan and his team at Optiva.
DAN DYER: I'm Dan Dyer.
I work in product
management at Optiva,
and we've been working
with these guys
on getting our application
to work on GKE On-Prem.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Cool.
So a lot of the session is going
to be focused on a real world
rollout.
So Kyle from Arctiq went into
Optiva, took an app they had,
and deployed it.
And we're going to
cover some of the tips
and tricks and the technical
deep dives of what exactly
GKE On-Prem is.
But before that, I
want to just talk
a little bit about what
problems we're trying to solve,
what the vision for
Anthos is as we move on.
And this really started
from a lot of customers
that we were talking
to in GKE, like folks
that were already in cloud.
And they said, we're doing
our modernization right now.
We have all these apps.
We're trying to move them
from VMs over to containers,
and we're bought into a subset
that can run on the cloud,
but there's so many
other scenarios out there
that we need to run in
physical data centers
or in edge locations.
So a common scenario
that I've heard
is like, oh, we want a
cluster in every store,
or we want a cluster
at every oil site,
or we need to have this workload
running in a particular region
where we can't necessarily
move everything into the cloud.
And the message from
that was really-- we
want to use Kubernetes,
because we've
heard about all
of these benefits
around portability
and abstraction.
Kubernetes has really
become the standard
for trying to make these
environments consistent.
But if you've ever tried to take
an off the shelf distribution
and get it up and
running yourself,
it just takes forever.
And I think getting it
installed is the easy part.
What is really challenging
for a lot of customers
is all the day two operations.
So having scaled out
masters, making sure
that you can do
security patches,
doing disaster
recovery and backups,
and these are all the features
that we gave out of the box
with GKE.
So these customers
were like, well,
let's see if we can
bring GKE On-Prem
and build this package
software that we
can deploy in these sites.
And that was sort
of the beginning
of our journey for Anthos.
But the thing I want
you guys to leave with--
this is really much more
than just Kubernetes.
We use Kubernetes as that
base abstraction layer
to have a portable environment.
But as Kelsey says,
this is really
the start of what
will hopefully be
a bunch of higher level tools
that can run on this platform.
And I like to describe the
building blocks of Anthos
as primarily three
open-source technologies--
Kubernetes for the
infrastructure pieces,
Istio for the
security management,
service management
stuff, and then finally
at the top, Knative cloud-run
type of environments where
you can have that
developer to an experience
so your devs don't have to work
directly with like Kubernetes
YAML or go into the details
of configuring Istio traffic
splitting.
They can just work with
higher level constructs.
And the thing that
we've really done
to build out Anthos
and figure out
how this thing is
going to run is
we want to take the
deployment and have it
running these different sites.
But the real power,
and what I like
to call sort of the
brain, that powers
all of these different locations
of Kubernetes, Istio, Knative,
and these other pieces, is this
Anthos hybrid control plane.
This is the stuff that runs
on Google Cloud Platform.
And the vision here is that we
have a single pane of glass,
we have a single hosted
service, that you
can use to programmatically
control clusters running
in these different sites.
And as we get into
the demo later on,
you'll get to see how we've
done this between GKE and GKE
On-Prem, where you
can start to use
the same tools, the same
workflows all in the cloud,
and have that go and federate
out to the various locations.
The real personas, the
real people that we really
want to try and target with
this is-- in a big enterprise
organization, which I
imagine many of you are in,
there's all these
different specialty roles.
And the key value prop
of Anthos is really
making sure that we have
the right building blocks
and the right tools
for each one of them.
We've sort of already talked
about the Kubernetes layer,
where we can take the
things for GKE On-Prem,
put them on your
existing hardware running
on top of VMware, and
keep those consistent.
The Istio pieces or the
cloud service mesh pieces
are really there for your
NetOp, your SecOps people.
Those are the ones that want
increased observability,
better secure connections
in between services,
and more control over what's
going on in your environment.
And then the
developer experience--
so we want to make sure to have
a nice, easy set of building
blocks for having a platform
as a service type features
so that your devs can just
push code and have it deployed
to the various clusters.
Now Anthos, like I said,
is a much bigger effort.
What I want to talk
about specifically
in this presentation
is GKE On-Prem.
So this is the footprint where
we take GKE and we install it
on top of your stack.
And before we get
into the details,
I want Dan to introduce
Optiva a little bit
and give you an
idea of what his use
case was for this
particular proof of concept.
DAN DYER: So I'm a
bit challenged here.
I have to do two things at
once, two different hands.
So I'm Dan Dyer.
Like I said, I run product
management at Optiva.
We are a business
support company
that runs charging systems
for some of the larger
telecoms in the world.
We have over 100
customers deployed,
80 countries, do three
billion-plus transactions.
The main product
that we're going
to talk about today, what
we did that prototype with,
the proof of concept, is what we
called Optima Charging Engine.
It's a tier one charging engine.
That means that this is
built for the biggest telecom
companies in the world.
It does primarily
rating and charging.
It's got quite a
bit of functionality
in terms of how
you customize it,
how you can build
it specifically
for your environment,
what it integrates with.
But the big things
here you should
think about is that this is
mission-critical application
for telecom companies.
If this doesn't work, their
billing system doesn't work
and they don't make any money.
So pretty important from their
perspective that it scales,
that it runs at a high
level of reliability,
and that it can
operate efficiently.
So this is kind of
the overall stack.
Essentially, if you look at
the dark blue piece there,
that's the piece that
we're going to focus on.
It's part of a bigger system.
So it has to fit into
their entire environment.
One of the things
that a lot of people
don't quite internalize
as they start
to try to take an
enterprise application
and move it into more of a
cloud-native or Kubernetes
environment is that it's
not just take your app,
break it up maybe a
little bit, maybe not,
shove it over into
something like a VM
like you would traditionally,
and then run it.
There's a decent
amount of work that
needs to be done here in terms
of modifying your application.
So it's really
important that you
think about how you're going to
containerize and take advantage
of some of the specific
cloud-native applications
and technologies out there.
It's a good opportunity
to actually spend
some time looking at how
you can simplify your app.
It's also important to think
about some of the benefits
that you're trying
to get out of this
and invest in those, such as
the scaling and the automated
deployment and update.
So if you look at the
diagram on the left there,
that's your typical
virtualization model.
As we moved into a cloud-native,
Kubernetes-based deployment,
some of the things that we
really focused on, like I said,
first of all, is
you've really got
to think about how
you're going to change
the architecture
of the application
to take advantage of a lot
of cloud-native patterns.
That's critical both
from the perspective
of how your application
is going to behave,
but also how you're going
to be able to efficiently
operate and deploy it.
A lot of legacy applications
are using a bunch
of proprietary technology.
This is also an opportunity for
you to go out and start looking
at using open-source
tools like--
typically, like, for
example, we moved
a lot of our proprietary
monitoring tools
over to the ELK Stack,
and then leveraging
some things like Stackdriver
and things like that.
Key to the delivery
of this is our ability
to actually improve
our scalability
and our operational efficiency.
So if all we did was take this
thing and move it to the cloud
or move it to a
private cloud and we
didn't get a whole lot
of benefit out of it,
that was an interesting
exercise, but why did we do it?
So it's really critical that
you think about what you're
trying to achieve out of this--
what are your goals in terms
of your end SLA, your end
operational efficiency,
whether you're
trying to achieve high
reliability or a lower TCO.
Those are all things that you
need to think about in advance,
and we spent quite a bit
of time looking at that.
In any enterprise environment,
but especially in telecom,
it's relatively conservative.
People are not willing to bet
the farm on some new technology
right away.
So it's important
that you give people
an incremental step
through their options
so that they can
actually feel like they
can take the jumps as they
need to, as they're ready to,
and that their business
is able to adapt.
So on a typical
legacy environment,
you're sitting there with
a pretty rigid environment.
You have to
pre-provision everything.
There's a high cost.
As we move into the Kubernetes
On-Prem kind of scenario,
we get a much better flexibility
in terms of our deployment
options.
You can leverage bare metal
and a variety of private clouds
to do that.
The next step really when
you think about moving this,
if you're going to
do it incrementally,
is to start to split
out some of your systems
and run that in a
hybrid scenario.
And then, finally, if you're
trying to make this journey,
you move all the way
to the public cloud
and everything's running on a
managed service in the cloud.
And that is where
from our perspective
you get the most TCO benefit,
you get the most efficiency,
you're taking advantage
of all the reasons
why Google Cloud exists.
The end state, the
state of nirvana
if you want to call it in
terms of from the provider
side of things, is that
we can deploy pretty much
the same application with
small amounts of differences
whether it's in the public
cloud or private cloud.
That allows us to be
much more efficient.
It also allows us to
run the same code.
It allows people
to migrate easily.
The hybrid story or
the public cloud story
becomes much better
when you do that.
And so, that's
really the promise
that we see with GKE
On-Prem is that if you look
at this diagram, beside
some of our storage
and database managed
services that we're trying
to use in the cloud, we
can pretty much end up
with the same application.
And as you'll see with
the proof of concept,
that's where we ended up.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Cool.
So before I hand
it over to Kyle,
I want to give at
least some context.
Like, how does GKE On-Prem
work from an architecture
perspective?
So you get the bits
for GKE On-Prem,
and how this comes packaged
is you get an admin OVA
workstation.
This is just a tool
you can spin up
on a VM in your
VMware environment
that you can use to bootstrap
the rest of your cluster.
So the first thing you
do is you run prepare.
This runs some
pre-validations checks.
We've added support for
downloading container images
to things like
private registries
for folks that have offline
and air gapped installs.
We've also added support during
the install process for things
like static IP
allocation for folks
that don't have DeepCP
setup in those environments.
But the end state
is that you end up
with this single long live node
called admin control plane,
and this is really the
orchestrator for all
of the On-Prem clusters.
All of the commands that you're
going to be using interact with
this admin control
plane, and for instance,
if you want to
create new clusters--
we've called them user
clusters in this example--
you go in and run a
create cluster command,
and go and spin up these
different environments.
So right now we do have a
separate utility from G Cloud.
Over time I think you'll
start to see G Cloud, our CLI,
merge with some
of these commands
so that we can invoke these
from a single environment.
But for now, we've just built
a nice lightweight CLI package
in order to spin up
these new clusters.
Once you have all of
your clusters spun up,
or just even a single
cluster, the next step
is registering this cluster
with our Cloud Console.
And this is the
piece where we can
start to do more of the
single pane of glass,
and also the remote
management of GKE On-Prem.
So you walk through a simple
flow in our Cloud Console.
The things it'll ask you for
is doing some metadata exchange
and then some credentials
to access that cluster.
After you go and connect, one of
the pieces that gets downloaded
is this lightweight
connection agent.
This thing sits next
to your API server
and allows us to go
from the Cloud Console
and reach into that API server
and issue a kubectl command.
One of the nice
things about this
is that every
authentication flow for this
happens as the end
user credential.
So if your developers
want to use this,
they will only see
things that they
are authenticated to see even
for these On-Prem clusters.
So if there are certain
namespaces that they only
have visibility to,
only those name faces
will show up for them
inside the console.
Now the number one
question we get
is around this external
connectivity like what
is this-- how does it work?
We wanted something that was
nice, quick, and easy out
of the box experience.
So the GKE connect agent is
really a lightweight gRPC proxy
that we can use to
access these API servers
and running in these
various environments.
No VPN is needed, no
direct interconnect
to get these things set up, and
you have a secure connection
to the control plane.
This really is just
for control plane data.
So this is not like replacing
a fat pipe of monitoring,
telemetry, and all that stuff.
They have their own data, data
pipeline, data path things.
But this really
gives the ability
to have that single
pane of glass experience
for all of the
different environments.
We're going to talk a lot more
about networking and storage
a bit later, but we wanted
to do it as part of the demo
so you could actually see
it working in real time.
So with that, Kyle, over to you.
KYLE BASSETT: All right.
So we decided we're going to
give a pretty in-depth demo.
The original plan was
to do a live demo,
but there's a lot to cover.
So I thought it'd be better
if we covered it all,
and we're going to have
more of an open discussion
and give you some opinions
on what we put together.
The Optiva app is
a pretty cool app.
They've done a good job
making it cloud native,
and it runs in GKE today.
So much of the exercise of what
we wanted to do as far as goals
was develop a lot of
knowledge around it
and prove that we could
port this application
in a short period of
time over to GKE On-Prem.
And also just get
something working,
and then start to scale
test it, and start
to do all the resiliency
things that we wanted to do.
So we're pretty pleasantly
surprised with how quick
we got it up, and
working with Dan's teams,
we got through it
pretty quickly.
So we'll dive into the details.
And I know a lot of people
haven't seen it at all.
So we're going to try to
show what it looks like.
We did this in five weeks.
So we had a pretty
aggressive timeline.
That is everything from getting
the servers that we used racked
and stacked, and getting ESX
on them, deploying all the base
components.
Optiva leverages Cloud Build
and GCR in the cloud today.
So we want to be able
to leverage that process
and that CI process and pull the
images down locally, and then
be able to deploy them.
Everything was done
in Helm templates.
So that made it a lot easier for
us to deploy and get things up,
but we also needed things
like persistent storage
that we're going to get into
and talk about those aspects.
And week four was really
about-- let's start
to throw some load
at this, and let's
see if the
scalability components
that Optiva has in
their application--
can we scale pods?
Can we scale nodes
on the back end?
We really beat up on
the cluster pretty good.
So we had to get another
node added this week
to be able to actually test
some of the scaling components.
And then we wrapped
up with documentation
and making sure everybody
knew what was going on.
The slide's not really painting
properly for some reason,
but it was a pretty
cool project.
That is a map of the world.
[LAUGHTER]
Just picture it.
And we were 100% remote.
None of us have met in person.
Optiva has a very distributed
team of experts around
that are very skilled.
So we did this all over
Slack, Google Hangouts,
collaboration tools.
So it just goes
to show you don't
need the card pass to
go into a data center
to build a private
cloud anymore.
You can do it
completely remotely.
So that was a
pretty cool project
to see it be
completely distributed.
So I guess we're going
to dive over to the demo?
WESTON HUTCHINS: Yeah.
One of the things I wanted
to say on the previous slide
is just--
we packaged some stuff out
of the box with GKE On-Prem.
You get things like monitoring.
You get OIDC connections
through identity providers.
But Optiva had a lot of
existing tools and technologies,
like Sysdig, Harbor, and
vaults, and stuff like that.
As part of that, because
like Kyle went in there
and plugged those
into the system,
which we'll show right now.
So you can take
your existing stack
and integrate those
into GKE On-Prem.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah.
I think the main point
with this is really
it was just another region for
us to deploy to in the end.
We were able to use a lot of
the same tools and techniques,
a few changes obviously around
storage and networking, which
we're going to get into.
But it really just looks like
another deployment target
for Optiva today,
which is really--
as Dan talked about--
was really the ultimate goal.
So we'll flip over to the demo.
So we're going to go through a
bunch of different components
here, and I think we'll have
a few comments to say around
them.
We're going to start
at what this looks
like at the very least of it.
So I've created some
aliases in this demo.
So you're going to
see A is your kubectl,
but it's pointing at
the admin cluster,
so the part Wes talked about
that manages the environment
and can bootstrap
additional clusters.
U is the user cluster.
User cluster is where
we put all the Optiva
applications, and
all the pods, and all
the supporting infrastructure.
You're going to see
some namespaces.
So if we look at
the admin cluster--
so you recognize these
type of namespaces
in a regular Kubernetes cluster.
If we look at the user cluster,
you see things like GKE Connect
that Wes talked about.
You see Harbor.
You see Istio.
And the OCE pieces are
the Optiva application.
So that's where we put all of
the pods that went into there.
If you look at nodes, the
admin cluster is fairly small.
Multi-master support's
coming in the release
that's dropping very soon.
And then if you look
at our bottom cluster,
we have 11 nodes.
So essentially these
are 11 worker nodes
that are able to process load.
And we've done some scaling
up and scaling down.
That's why you see one of them
is a little bit shorter time.
We got this demo put
together yesterday.
So you're probably wondering
what it looks like in vCenter.
It looks just like any of your
other vCenter environments.
There's nothing really
special about it.
We started with a clean cluster.
We obviously need to be
able to call the API.
GKE On-Prem has fully
orchestrated all the VM
provisioning.
You're really not having to
go and clobber around vCenter
at all after you set it up.
So once you provision
user cluster,
this piece is all automated.
We're leveraging data
stores on the back end.
We have a few different
data stores, SSD, HDD.
We're also leveraging
persistent storage, which
we'll talk about a little bit.
But as far as this
goes, it looks
a lot like any other cluster.
We're leveraging
a template to be
able to spin up the base node
before it gets bootstrapped.
We've got a bunch of
different data stores.
We've got some different
virtual switches.
There's a lot of flexibility
on how that stuff's configured,
and we've just put everything
in a resource group
to keep it separate.
So no reason why you
couldn't use a shared cluster
that you already have to
get this up and running.
Clearly we need to be
able to call the API
and orchestrate a lot
of these capabilities.
Another piece
that's part of this
is we are using an F5 virtual
appliance to do all the ingress
pieces, and that's
also orchestrated.
So if you do carve
out an ingress inside
of the environment, it will use
the container connector piece
that F5 provides
to carve out these.
We're going to
show a demo of how
we're able to do that
dynamically near the end.
So it's able to orchestrate
all the front end.
I know, Wes, there's
always lots of questions
around ingress networking
and some stuff that's coming.
Do you want to comment on
some of the stuff that's
coming down the line?
WESTON HUTCHINS: Yeah.
So one of the common
questions we get
is, what's the dependency on F5?
So we really wanted that
out of box experience
where you could use Kubernetes
to provision load balancer
support right out of the box.
But we have heard from
customers that they already
run things like HAProxy
or Nginx instead of F5.
So one of the things we are
going to be adding pretty soon
is going to be the ability to
bring your own load balancer
and plug into that.
I think longer-term
you'll start to see maybe
a Google provided load
balancer out of the box.
But we're kind of listening
to the customer feedback
around some of these
hard dependencies,
or I have different
environments already in there.
KYLE BASSETT: So
you can see here
that we are looking
at the user cluster.
If you look in the
top right partition
we also have the admin cluster.
As we extend more
clusters, you'll
get more partitions obviously.
So these are the base ones.
You can see there's
an Istio space.
We've got a virtual
server list that's
been populated through when
we're plumbing these pieces.
We've been playing around
with container connector
a little bit.
We can put F5 in the SDN range
and skip the whole node port
piece.
So that's something
we're looking
at doing, and then introducing
other load balancers
and things like that.
DAN DYER: Yeah.
I think one other thing from
the application provider
perspective we're coming from--
it's critical that
we don't want to be
in the entire
infrastructure business.
We want to be able to go in
and fit into the environment
that the customer is in.
And so the ability
to take advantage
of a private cloud
like this and put
some standard implementation
on top of it like GKE,
and then us being
able to just leverage
that and go in and
take advantage of that,
and take advantage
of the infrastructure
that the customer's
already built,
to me, that's a
critical value add here
that this is shown to
be pretty successful at.
KYLE BASSETT: OK, so Wes
talked about the connector
and where you manage this from.
So not everybody's
a Kubernetes expert.
Not everybody wants to be
running kubectl commands.
So we can leverage Google Cloud
Platform's admin station or web
UI to be able to look
at all our clusters
and start to see what's
going on with them and diving
into the detail.
So I showed you
earlier the node list.
This is the exact same
view through here,
and you'll be able to see you
get quite a bit of insight
into what's going on into here.
We're going to show some
Stackdriver integration
and stuff like that.
But if you look at our
cluster, here's our cluster,
there's no reason why we
couldn't have other regions
that are cloud-based in here.
The whole idea is it's a common
experience across your on-prem
and your cluster
inside the cloud.
DAN DYER: Yeah.
That really is critical
to that hybrid strategy
we're talking about
that if you can
have the same point of control
and management visibility
to both your on-prem
and the stuff
you start to move
into the cloud,
then it just becomes much
easier to make that move.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Yeah.
One of the things
that I hear a lot,
and I heard it from Dan too,
is these enterprise customers
who are trying to train their
IT staff and their developers
to think more like the cloud.
Well, this is that
bridge where you
can start to use a
lot of the tooling,
but you can still
operate it on-prem.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah.
So we'll look through
the-- obviously
there's going to be more
components added to this,
but we can look at all our pods.
So usually you're trying
to kubectl, describe pod,
get the pod name.
You can really drill down
through it all through here,
and you can see what
storage it's using.
You can see any events.
You can also look at
the YAML configuration.
So this is a big piece of I
think what people are looking
for as far as a managed
solution, is having
the toolkit to be able
to manage upgrades
and manage the lifecycle
of my clusters,
be able to provision
pieces through there.
We're working pretty hard
to build a lot of the CI/CD
toolkit into this
workflow and be
able to use a lot
of Google toolkits
that we were comfortable
with using in cloud,
and leverage them
on-prem as well.
So I mentioned storage.
Here's all the
[? PBs. ?] Everyone
says applications that move to
Kubernetes don't need state.
We always find out they
need state about an hour
into the discussion.
So there's quite a few
[? PB ?] requirements
in this environment.
We'll dive into that.
You can see all the config
maps and configuration.
Secrets are obviously protected.
You need an elevated
account to be
able to go in and look
at any of that stuff.
Anything you want to say about
just the experience, Wes,
around managing this
stuff and leveraging
some of the other tools?
WESTON HUTCHINS: Yeah.
So I think the long-term vision
for this is that all of those
cloud services that you were
mentioning-- so Cloud Build,
cloud-hosted
Spinnaker deployments,
doing policy management
inside the cloud, as well--
these are the
pieces that we want
to have run in the
cloud environment,
be able to access
these clusters.
And so for the most part,
we want this to feel--
I think Kyle said it best.
He's like, this is an
extension of your region.
It's just running in
a different location.
I think long-term, let's say
over the next couple of years,
we'll start to see more
things where we have,
let's say, global load balancers
that can maybe route traffic
intelligently through
clusters running
in these various environments.
So there's a really
cool long-term story
about how we can
have this brain that
can federate out to these
different environments.
KYLE BASSETT: Great.
So Stackdriver is integrated.
We can get metrics and logs into
GCP right from the clusters.
Wes mentioned some of the
other toolkit we deployed.
So we deployed
Sysdig really early.
We knew that we needed
to test this at scale.
And we wanted to get a
really good baseline.
So it was a good way to start
from nothing, with no load,
and then ramp the
load up and really
get into the network stack
and see what was going on.
So we've created
some base dashboards.
Now, the nice part is,
we've got a good baseline.
We can really start
ramping up the load
till this thing starts to
fall down, and really learn
where we need to scale it.
We can dive right
into the network view.
Really, we're looking
at every single system
call across all microservices.
And we can drill down to
see the length of time
and what's, exactly,
happening in it.
So getting these
dashboards in place really
sets us up for future success
as we start to tune this.
DAN DYER: Yeah.
And one of the
things that you'll
find as you start to try to move
a legacy app to be cloud native
is that--
so you're going
to decompose that.
You're going to break
it into little pieces.
And all of the learnings
that you had before
are still relevant, but
you're going to find out
that you have new bottlenecks.
Or maybe things aren't
quite connecting the way
you used to think they were.
And so having these
kind of tools in here
to be able to go down and
drill down and find out
where your problems are, where
your new bottlenecks are, what
kind of performance
you're getting--
that's critical to the
success of projects.
And this really helped
us out, because we
did run into a few issues
where we were either
under-provisioned or had
made some bad choices
in terms of configuration.
And we were easily able to
come back and figure out
what the problem was and
address it pretty easily.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah.
So it's just deployed as a
daemon set in all the nodes.
We'll probably wait
for questions, but--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I didn't catch what
you said there.
What was the tool you used?
KYLE BASSETT: Oh, it's Sysdig.
So Sysdig is a SaaS tool,
monitoring, analytics tool.
It's really focused
on containers.
So it's capturing every
system call, essentially.
And it's got a whole
analytics engine.
The nice part is the dashboard.
So being able to graph data
and look at it over time
and saying, why did it get
slow, and drilling down-- that's
what we really used it for.
So helped us aggregate all
those logs and things like that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KYLE BASSETT: No problem.
So I mentioned Harbor.
So Harbor's a CNCF project.
We're a CNCF member.
So we wanted to avoid having
to pull container images
down every time we
built them over the pipe
that Optiva has up to GCP.
So we deployed
Harbor as a container
to look after the
registry components.
So we have a sync job.
When their build process runs,
we can pull the containers down
to the local LAN.
And then when we're
building and deploying
the applications via
the home templates,
we're just pulling
off the local network.
So Harbor was a nice
little registry to use.
Really easy to get
up and running.
No reason why you couldn't
leverage Artifactory
or some enterprise registry
that you're already using today.
This is just the way we
solved it for this project.
DAN DYER: Yeah.
And this is another
enterprise-specific thing.
If you're going to try
to take this approach
to do this with
your application,
obviously, there's a
high sensitivity to churn
and being able to
prequalify things
in the customer environment.
So having the ability to
stage like this and then
try things out in parallel--
that's a huge strength of this
that you wouldn't
necessarily get
in a traditional environment
where you'd have to build up
an entire parallel system.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah.
So I think there's
upwards of 60 or 80 images
that we're leveraging in this.
So everybody is always
interested in storage.
So we thought we'd cover a
little bit on the storage side.
Natively, the default
storage provider for GKE
today is a vSphere
cloud provider.
So essentially
what that does is,
allows you to
dynamically provision
block-based volumes
via the platform.
So what it's doing
is dynamically
carving out a VMDK
on the back end
and attaching it to the host and
then providing that access back
to the container.
So we leveraged
this for anything
that needed persistent storage.
There is an NFS
provider that has RWX.
We didn't have time
to test that yet.
It's something we're
definitely looking at doing.
Other pieces that we're looking
to test as we move forward
are more cloud-native
storage options.
So we did some testing of Rook,
which is another CNCF project.
But we're looking at things
like Robin and Portworx.
A lot of customers
are leveraging
back-end NetApp
appliance, but they
have a Trident plug-in
that you can leverage.
So storage is
what's nice about it
if you don't know
Kubernetes very well--
it's very, very plugable.
All the components are plugable.
You could run multiple
storage options here.
And the way they
work-- and we'll
show you in a little bit-- is,
it's just a default storage
class.
Or you have different
storage classes.
You may have a storage class for
SSD, a storage class for HDD.
You can put policies
and rules and quotas
and stuff around that.
So I'll show you how easy it is.
Anybody, again, if you're
not familiar with Kubernetes
and you've been asking for
volumes in a VM world--
change record, wait, go
buy the guy a coffee--
the idea behind all this stuff
is, it's all very declarative.
So all you have to do
to carve a storage out
in this environment is this
simple YAML configuration.
I run that, I immediately
get a PV created.
And then in a couple minutes,
I'll end up getting that ready.
So now we've got a 2 gig volume
ready to go for me to leverage
in my application.
Literally takes
a couple seconds.
What you'll see
now is, using govc,
we're calling the vSphere API.
You can see it's carved out the
VMDKs on the back end for us.
And that's just leveraging
a regular data store
that you would leverage in
your VMware environment.
Nothing special.
Just need the plugin.
So we'll just go ahead
and delete the PV.
You can see the PV's gone.
We'll call vCenter again.
And there's nothing left.
So that's just a
look at storage.
Storage is something
that, like I said,
everyone thinks all
these Kubernetes
workloads are ephemeral.
They're generally not.
There's a lot of stuff
that does need state.
So there's lots of
good storage providers
out there that we can leverage.
Next, we're going to talk
about autoscaling a little bit.
Autoscaling seems to be
a conversation that I
have with every customer.
And we always have lots
of religious debates
on what they really want.
But Optiva really has a
business case for this.
And it's built into
their platform.
So, Dan, do you want to talk
about just the advantages
and why you guys feel
it's so important
and what it does for you?
DAN DYER: Sure.
So in the telecom business,
especially calling,
for example, or even data,
it tends to be very cyclical.
So both across the day you
can see cycles, as well as
across the year.
So first thing in
the morning, you
might have a spike in calls.
Or on a certain holiday, you
So if you look at this
chart that we have here,
that's what that wavy curve is--
the sine wave kind of thing.
And you also tend to have
some kind of long-term trend
in terms of growth.
Or you might even
have long-term trend--
hopefully not, but you
might have a long-term trend
in drop of traffic.
And so if you look at
that step line there,
that's traditionally
how you have
dealt with it in a hardware,
bare metal kind of environment.
You have to predict in advance.
You have to over-provision.
If you under-provision, then you
get that little red triangle,
which means you've just failed
your application on a probably
pretty regular basis.
People are dropping calls.
And if you're way down
there below the blue line,
then you're
over-provisioned and you're
paying for a bunch of
hardware to generate heat.
So it's really critical
for our business.
And there's a lot of other
businesses like this that
have these kind of patterns.
And so in the public cloud,
this is a no-brainer.
You can provision VMs
in the background.
But even in a private
cloud environment,
if you have shared
infrastructure
with a little bit of
additional capacity,
or you're trying
to do some testing,
or even you have, say, a
special holiday that you
need to pre-provision
for, this scenario
can take advantage of the
autoscaling capabilities
that we have in GKE and
also in our application
so that you're not
wasting a lot of hardware
and you're able to
adapt as you need to go.
KYLE BASSETT: So
we're going to show--
when Dan and I first talked,
one of the big things
we wanted-- success criteria--
was, let's get to the point
where we can autoscale.
So the discussion went,
well, pods are somewhat easy.
Their application
can scale in cloud.
Google's got tons of capacity,
so that part of the problem's
pretty easy to solve.
But in the VMware world,
we need to have capacity.
And, essentially, another
node is another VM.
So we can orchestrate
and automate that.
Since the whole
platform's declarative,
as we talked about,
it was pretty doable.
We've done some work with
Configuration Manager
to be able to do this
more in a GitOps fashion
so that everything would
be source of truth in Git.
You do a pull request,
you change a node count,
gets approved, automatically
goes and spins up the clusters.
So we'll show you the
capability of that.
We've also-- we're
putting out a blog,
I think later today,
that demos that.
But you can see here, we
have 11 nodes running.
And what this is,
this OCS process
is essentially the workers that
are processing all the call
volume and doing all the
analytics and all the billing.
So we can only
handle so much load.
And Optiva's
application, when it
gets under certain conditions,
it knows how to scale up.
So we're going to go
through the use case.
And you can see here, we're
using Grafana and Prometheus
on the back end.
That's part of
their application.
So the green represents
calls per second.
So this test, we've got up to
about 60,000 calls per second
with this environment.
The blue line represents number
of pods that are running.
So we're generally running
that one pod that I showed you.
But once load comes up, we
need to scale to two and then
beyond if we keep
cranking it up.
So if you look at
these graphs, you
can see we were upwards of
30,000 transactions here.
We scaled down, so our
pod scaled back down.
So this is pod-level
scaling in Kubernetes,
working off metrics.
We're pushing about 10,000 a
second at this point in time.
So this stuff's
fairly out of the box.
And you can see we
ran a lot of tests.
And we were pushing load,
dropping load, pushing load,
dropping load.
So you can see, it's
very consistently
scaling up and scaling down.
And our error rates
are almost nothing.
We're able to handle the load.
Optiva's got a nice little
load generator for us.
So they built a
great little tool
that we can go in and
just slide the bar.
So we'll jump it up to about
40,000 a second right now.
The nice part is,
we're leveraging
Prometheus on the back end.
Everything's real
time on the graphs.
So you can see, their
software has said,
Kubernetes says, let's spin
up another pod with three more
containers to handle this.
So load goes up pretty quickly.
Pod scales to two or starts to
bring all the containers up.
And Dan mentioned that red
line in his diagram earlier.
So we're up to 40,000.
The red line's
representing, our error rate
is starting to go up because,
as I showed you earlier,
we are pushing the cluster,
from a resource perspective,
pretty hard with our five
nodes and our 11 nodes
on the back side.
But here, you can
represent, now,
the second pod is running here.
DAN DYER: Just one comment.
The scaling we're
doing here is--
this is a nice
thing, once again,
if you're not that
familiar with Kubernetes.
This is just a standard
autoscaler based on CPU.
You can do a lot more
elaborate things.
And we're looking
at implementing
those in the future.
But getting something like
this working in Kubernetes
and in this environment
is not rocket science.
So if you structured
your application properly
so that the pieces can be
independently run and scaled
in containers, then it's pretty
straightforward to just build
yourself an autoscaler in
there that can handle that
based on CPU load, for example.
KYLE BASSETT: So we've
scaled the load back down.
So things are going to
start behaving again,
because it's going to match
the capacity that we need.
You'll see that Kubernetes is
terminating the other pods.
We don't need it anymore.
Now we're back down to one load.
We're back down to a
standard processing.
Now, obviously, the
issue with that use case
was, we didn't have enough
nodes in the back end.
So we have to solve the node
scaling problem so that we can
solve the pod scaling problem.
And everything in GKE, I
mentioned, is declarative.
So Wes, do you want to comment
on just the approach of how
you built the automation and why
you built it the way you did?
WESTON HUTCHINS: Yeah.
So a lot of the
architecture for GKE On-Prem
is based off of something
in the open source
we've been working on
called the cluster API.
And what it allows you
to do is define the shape
of your cluster, the Kubernetes
version, the add-ons you
want to install.
And then you can also
define the nodes.
So you can define
what images you're
going to deploy on them, what
Kubernetes components are
running on those.
And what Kyle's is
going to show here
is, scaling, at this
point, is really
just a simple matter
of going and changing
the node count from 11
to 12, checking that
into a Git repository.
And then the cluster is
looking for these changes,
syncing them down.
And then it's just a matter of
our machinery going and saying,
hey, I noticed a change.
I need to move from 11 to 12.
Let's go and bump
the cluster up.
And the really nice
thing about this is--
you'll probably hear the
term "cluster is cattle."
We're going to start moving
down this direction where
you can have these portable
metadata environments that
describe your clusters.
And you can spin these up in
different locations really
quickly.
But the source of truth
is all in a Git repo.
And it's all declarative.
And you can put
[INAUDIBLE] around that.
You can put change request
validation and things
like that.
Super nice way to deploy
and manage clusters.
KYLE BASSETT: So I paused
it here for a second.
The bottom right-hand corner is
us monitoring the vCenter API.
So you see, we saved the file
in the top left automatically.
We've got vCenter API
picking up that that
changed the declarative nature.
And we'll flip over to
vCenter in a second.
You're going to see that
the nodes are automatically
coming up.
And they're going to get
added to the cluster.
So you see here, on the bottom,
we're powering on the VM
from template.
Within a very short period
of time, the node comes up.
You can see it's up.
We don't have an IP
address yet, but it's
going to get an IP
address very quickly.
And it's going to
join the cluster.
And now we've got an
extra node in the cluster.
So you see on the bottom left,
we've got our node online now.
It's been on for 1 second.
It's not ready.
It's bootstrapping.
And that'll change
pretty quickly
and be able to come
onto a ready state.
One of the interesting things
that we found out early
is, Optiva in GKE makes a couple
kernel tweaks to their nodes.
So we had never
really tested that.
So it was good to
know that we actually
could make those
tweaks that they
needed, that they had in cloud.
So top-right corner-- we
just solved this, currently,
with an Ansible playbook.
So we wrote an idempotent
Ansible playbook.
We just add to the
inventory file, run it.
It'll automatically make the
kernel tweak, reboot the host.
And now the node's a first-class
citizen in the cluster.
Plan on this is, since
we have a VM template,
what we're going to do is
just put it into the template.
And then we won't need the
Ansible playbook to run.
So it'll just be spun
into the template.
WESTON HUTCHINS:
I know this can be
kind of hard to see
for folks in the back,
but we'll publish this online.
And we'll also have
a blog post that
goes into a lot more
of these details.
KYLE BASSETT: Yeah.
So in this case, this is
just straight up Ansible
We're running it
against the node.
The node's going
to take the change.
You can see it skipped all
the ones that we've already
made the change to.
The node will go not ready.
And then it's really fast.
Within 20, 30 seconds,
the node comes back up.
And what you'll find is,
when I describe the node,
we've automatically deployed
all the daemon sets.
So we have a Sysdig daemon set.
We've got a bunch of
different daemon sets
that are running for the
environment that we need.
And now, we'll get to
the point where, let's
scale this up even higher.
And let's see how it performs
this time, from an [? air ?]
perspective.
So we pump it up to 62,000
transactions per second.
You're going to immediately
see, the Grafana dashboards
are going to ramp up.
We're going to get
our second pod scaled.
And we don't have
a lot of errors
because we've got the
right capacity to be
able to handle the volume.
So having these load
generators and loads tests
were just really critical for
us to be able to actually test
this stuff.
Trial and error, some
different tweaks and settings.
And having a really
good monitoring setup
allowed us to get
the baseline of that.
So two other quick
things to show you.
Everyone's wondering,
why haven't they talked
about the networking yet?
So we'll talk about
networking quickly.
Wes, do you want to comment
just generally on the networking
strategy and [INAUDIBLE]?
WESTON HUTCHINS: Yeah.
So the way we've architected
the footprint of GKE On-Prem
is that each cluster
is an island.
So they form an IP
mesh in between them.
But everything that is
connected outside the cluster
has to get [? natted ?] out.
We are using BGP, so we do
have a theoretical 50-node max
for a lot of these cluster
sizes that we've started out at.
But we're going to
expand this over time.
And we use Calico
for network policy.
I already talked about F5.
We use that for the
L4 load balancer
where we can actually go and
spin up service-type load
balancer and have that
route traffic into it.
And eventually, we
will have the ability
to make that plugable so you
can actually go and bring
a different load balancer
service in there.
KYLE BASSETT: So I mentioned
how hard it is to carve storage.
We all know how
hard it is to get
a rule put into your
F5 box, and how many
tickets and coffees that takes.
This is, if you're not
familiar with Kubernetes--
it's kind of the same thing.
We just run a simple
kubectl command.
We've got a famous
beer Giphy app
that we've just deployed there.
We've also created the endpoint.
This is the entire
configuration of the endpoint.
This integrates into F5.
So all of this is
sending API calls.
You can see, we
go back to our F5.
We're in the user space.
We've got four endpoints.
If I refresh, we automatically
get our default ingress.
If we go look at
that, you can see
we've got a cluster
IP we're leveraging.
If we go to our application
that we just deployed,
we've got our random
beer Giphy up and running
in a matter of seconds.
So that's it for the demo side.
Maybe we'll flip back to the
slides and just close out.
So tips and lessons learned--
everyone's probably interested
on that.
I think we can all
make a few comments.
Environment sizing is important.
We knew this was
a big application.
When we first started
with four nodes,
we got the
application up, but we
were right at the edge of
leveraging the amount of CPU
and memory that we needed.
So Optiva, being a very
agile team-- this cluster
is actually deployed in Berlin.
We were able to get
another node added to it
and were able to keep
the project moving.
So make sure you size
your environment.
We got into a few
interesting issues
that we need to look into.
When we were pushing
load heavy against pods
that had PV
requirements, DRS was
starting to do more than
it should have and started
moving environments around.
So we decided to disable DRS
for a lot of these environments.
We really didn't need
stuff moving around.
I mentioned monitoring
tools, getting all that stuff
in place early so you
have a good baseline.
Anything else you guys
want to add to the--
DAN DYER: Yeah.
One of the things I think
is a natural tendency
is to spend a lot
of time thinking
about your operational
model before you do this.
A lot of people try to try
it out and see what happens.
And I think that it's really
critical, especially jumping
into new environment like
this, to really think
about your operational
model and things
like what type of monitoring
you need to put in place.
What do you want to monitor?
Who's getting access
to that kind of stuff?
I think the other really
cool thing about this was--
and we already alluded to
this, but we had already
spent the time to move our
app to GKE in the cloud.
But I was expecting
a lot more work
in terms of refactoring
our scripts,
in terms of
deployment and things
like that, to get this to work.
And yet, we had a pretty
minimal amount of work there.
So that's a really nice thing.
So if you're going to
invest the time in here,
I think the promise of GKE
On-Prem relative to the cloud--
it's definitely
delivering on that.
KYLE BASSETT: The other
piece I would mention
is, put some time into your
CICD deployment strategies.
Optiva had done a
really good job.
So there was a
couple of times when
we tested some weird things
and we wanted to start
from a clean slate again.
And that was an hour
and a half effort
to go and redeploy their entire
application after we built
the new cluster, which
was maybe a 40, 50 minute
exercise because we've
automated a lot of it.
So it gave us a
clean slate again.
And if we saw weird
things happening
because we were
experimenting, we
didn't have to
troubleshoot and wonder
if that was causing something.
We just repaved
the infrastructure.
Let's just rebuild it and let's
start from a clean slate again.
So this cluster got built
Sunday night, again.
And then we did this
demo last night.
So we're really comfortable at
standing it up and rebuilding
it again.
Other things to think about is--
Dan mentioned it, but
leveraging Helm charts
and just spending an
extra couple hours
writing that Ansible playbook
saved us a lot of time
down the road.
So when we had to
build the cluster,
we didn't have to
SSH into 11 VMs
and go and do the
kernel parameter.
So just roll up your sleeves,
do some Google searching.
Most of the
information's out there.
Reach out to us.
We'll share some of
these playbooks and stuff
that we've figured
out along the way.
And the only other
thing I would say
is, we did a stand up
every day with the team.
And everybody showed up to it.
Some days, it was just a chat.
But it also removed
any roadblocks
and kept everybody really in the
loop [? which ?] was going on.
So being a distributed
team and not
seeing each other
all the time, we
had 11 o'clock
stand up every day
and it really helped the
project move forward.
And it helped us get
rid of any roadblocks
and also provided good
updates to the stakeholders,
because we had a
pretty short runway
to get all this ready for Next.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Yeah.
I would say-- and
there's probably
going to be a lot of questions--
we'll be at the booth a lot.
You can also find us
on Twitter, email us.
We'll figure out
how to get in touch
and answer those
questions for you.
And I guess the
closing thing is just,
if you guys liked this talk,
go and give us some feedback.
And we'll be around.